money  only becomes valuable  when it is used  money is not valuable in the bank money  is not valuable sitting waiting for your  retirement it might give you some peace  of mind some some idea that you're going  to be fined and you're going to be  protected you know when you stop working  and that you're going to be able to  retire and live happily ever after  because you have money sitting on a 401k  or a retirement account or a  ira or you've got a bunch of money  sitting in a savings accounts but the  truth is you're you can't produce money  when it sits in a bank money is only  valuable only valuable when it's used  okay a millionaire gets a little bit of  money and the first thing they want to  do is protect their money  god makes a hundred grand first time in  his life he wants to protect his hunter  he makes five thousand first time he  wants to protect he goes into protection  rather than going out and getting more  money this is why people become  complacent